believe it or not meditation is going to
be something that would be really useful
one of the most effective things or
important things about meditation is its
ability to train you to focus so even
more than its going to give you these
powerful insights probably less useful
than the fact that it can help you
reduce anxiety and stress but really
really powerful element of meditation is
that by training yourself to come back
to the breath back to the breath back to
the breath over and over and over you'll
find that the length of time in between
your mind wandering gets longer and
longer over time and so you're actually
able to stay focused it's a great way to
train yourself for that the other thing
I would do is I would implement in your
life periods of intentional boredom so
don't always pull your phone out
practice just being with your thoughts
practice like have a go-to thing that
you're trying to think about or solve
maybe it's your business but don't just
accept that you have a hard time staying
focused don't just accept you get bored
easily you need to push this stuff
because you can't make changes in that
humans are an active species and one of
the things that drives our activity is
you will always have a thought in your
head the only way to learn to stop that
is by meditating and then as soon as you
stop meditating it's gonna come flooding
back it is the nature of the human mind
I'm very good with that a lot of good
things in my life have come from the
fact that I'm always obsessing over a
problem now meditating became super
important for me because when I didn't
do that I found what I call background
radiation would build I would just be
uneasy about a lot of things stacking up
in my head so learning to meditate was
super powerful
but it's been equally powerful that my
mind obsessively thinks about things so
I set my mind to a problem I say okay
this is the thing that I'm trying to
solve like literally right now I'm
working on a script which I was talking
about at the beginning of this live and
I stopped today because I hit a problem
that I thought this problem will succumb
to me taking a break and letting my
subconscious mind think about it but I
had to specifically state what the thing
was that I needed to solve for and so
once I have that locked
mind then it's there it's there as I'm
falling asleep it's there while I'm
meditating it's there when I'm showering
I can feel my mind just dipping into it
all the time and then there's a reason
that people say I need to sleep on it
right it's your subconscious mind
beginning to address the problem
I think that money mindsets are
something that are not talked about
enough because you could go from
wherever you are today to tripling your
income tripling and would your money
mindsets magically change no in fact we
have a lot of people some of whom are
notable well they're in a lot of
financial communities and they have
increased their earnings but they still
obsess over pennies and you look at them
and you say that like that that must be
sad or wow like they're so cheap these
are words that we use but the fact is
that once you figure out how to make
more money and there is a process for
making more money I've been teaching it
for 15 years this doesn't just come
along magically you have to engineer
this just as much as you engineer your
income that is why everyone has a
cheap-ass uncle who has a lot of money
but still checks everybody's expenses
when it comes to settling up the tap
everybody okay
that person learned how to make money
but they did not learn the accompanying
skill of changing their money mindset in
general when it comes to money in
America the vast majority of people know
and like frugality that is what they
know that's what they grew up with and
that is what they expect so when I
started talking after years of writing
about money stuff I started writing
about earning more a lot of people did
not like it and they started saying this
seems like a scam cuz earning more to a
lot of people seems like a scam
why because they've been raised with the
money mindset of this is all we have we
should be happy and we better protect it
don't let anybody tax us that's evil
ilysm Oh [ __ ] lunatics but they never
think about expanding the size of the
pie okay so when I started talking about
this is very uncomfortable it's like a
whole different world view and people
started unsubscribe they started leaving
first and trickles then in hoards
at that time I had about 50,000 email
subscribers over the course of the next
few years I would lose approximately 35
to 40,000 of those subscribers let me
say that again in case you didn't catch
it
I had 50,000 subscribers over the course
of the next few years I would lose
approximately 35,000 of those
subscribers do you understand what that
feels like and do you understand that at
the time I used an email service
provider that allowed people to write
why they were unsubscribed so every day
I'm getting 50 to 100 things that say
used to enjoy your stuff but nowadays I
dare ask and that went on for years how
do you think you would feel if you had
actually built something up where people
liked you and you were enjoying it but
then you decided to take a different
turn and a lot of them said you suck I'm
out of here not good it it really did
not feel good but at that moment I
realized a principle and that principle
is my future is bigger than my past and
I truly believe this
I believed that at the time I had been
writing about I don't know four four or
five years something like that and I
knew that I had decades to work on this
little site I called I will teach you to
be rich and decades to explore all kinds
of stuff I could never even imagine at
the time but I knew that the 35,000
people who were unsubscribing in the
grand scheme were just a
in the bucket I think that having that
principle is the one of the only things
that allowed me to keep going because if
I had simply looked at fifty thousand
going down every single day I would have
given up but I knew that my future was
bigger than my past and so I see this
principle now applied everywhere I see
people who come and sometimes they see
some of my fitness posts and they're
like I'm 47 or I'm 57 is it too late for
me fitness wise they ask the same thing
about money
10 times more I'm 50 I didn't start
investing at 22 like that one example in
your book is it too late for me my
answer is it's never too late it's never
too late to stop but we need to be
candid about how much we can achieve I
had something like a 65 year old woman
right knee and said I need to make
$100,000 in the next one year and I'm on
a fixed income so I need to make it
through investments unfortunately that's
not gonna happen
and sometimes we need to hear the candid
truth I to be very gentle about that
message so you won't make a hundred
thousand dollars off investments in one
year but the second best thing you can
do is to start now because you know what
else can you do you're just gonna give
up no let's start today's never too late
we can adjust what our expectations are
but let's start here are five books I
highly recommend imma start the first
one Bryan Holaday stillness is the key
you guys want to really learn how to
find stillness
and all of this uncertainty and anxiety
and stress and overwhelm this is a great
book of the Stoics that will teach you
how to find that stillness in yourself
meditation is something I've been doing
for a long time was meditating back in
high school in college with sports
learning about visualization learning
about calming the mind breath work this
is what we did as athletes to become
great athletes we did it every single
day in meditation there's so many
different forms this is the philosophy
behind it I was highly recommend
checking this out here's the second book
let me know if you've read this book the
Prophet this one is a spiritual classic
with more with millions of copies sold
in 40 different languages since 1923 I
recommend this one short one I like
short books because for me I'm a slow
reader so this is the second one the
Prophet make sure to check it out
the third one this is a goodie and a
favor to a lot of people but it's a
practical guide to personal freedom The
Four Agreements if you've read this one
check it out if you've read this one
check it out let me know four agreements
for me I've had to learn the hard way
many times about the four agreements
being impeccable be impeccable with your
word don't take anything personally
don't make assumptions and always do
your best a great book to learn why this
is important to check it out four
agreements are one McMahon is the way of
the warrior an ancient path to inner
peace again if you want to find inner
peace during this time of uncertainty
and stress and overwhelm the way of the
warrior by my friend Erwin McManus make
sure to check this book out really
powerful the warrior harnesses their
strength it's all about the lessons of
the warrior and you aren't a warrior my
friend and this one is a good one that a
friend told me about and I had no clue
this was out there but I read it in a
set sitting and it's really powerful
it's called rules for a knight I want
you to take this book out called rules
for a knight
and yes it's by the actual actor Ethan
Hawke which I thought is he gonna have a
good book who knows but I'll tell you
why this is a cool book it's it's about
some some papers that he found in a
basement and it was papers from a knight
from his ancestors who a night fearing
he may not return from battle writes a
letter to his children and attempt to
leave a record of everything he knows
that he'll never see them again and he
writes this letter to his kids so I
really like this book
Ethan Hawke
rule for a night school for a night so
these are the five books check out these
books if you want to take a screenshot
real quick you can so you can have all
these just as infectious as viruses so
is fear but so is hope so is kindness so
is compassion so is love so is wisdom
and that could spread also as well and
so what I would but I would suggest is
self-care and this time of cocooning you
know don't use this time to feed your
mind you know just negative stuff all
the time that I would avoid if you want
to make progress binge watching you know
all the shows on Netflix if that's your
prerogative to do that's absolutely good
also but we can't make excuses also at
the same time you know this sometimes
people tend to have entitlement where
they make excuses and you can't be upset
by the results you didn't get by the
actions you didn't take and you know use
this time intelligent and so I would use
a clarity I would use it for self care
for you and your loved ones you know
making sure you move and exercise and
I'm just like here like with my dr TRX
and you know just jump rope and moving
and so care for yourself and these are
my versions of kettlebells so if you're
a home you could be doing all this kind
of stuff if you have two of these you
can be doing lifts reading a lot of
stuff with boiling water i have colitis
balls and i'm sit around watching
television doing this or doing this but
you know what you can use heaven hands
upon juice think you can sit and do the
all kinds of things with cans you can be
doing this you can be doing lunges you
don't have to do a lot if you did the
play
every day the plank and push-ups and
that would be enough to keep you
exercising there's some core exercise
you do the plants and push-ups and
sit-ups that's really cool you need to
do this is the first time that I have
actually shown or done Kiner G digitally
and have been able to share it with all
of you guys we just got off tour with
WWE and Oprah which was incredible we
got to share this with a hundred and
thirty-five thousand people collectively
and to see the transformation happen
within just the 15 minutes was
mind-blowing whereas the usual kinder
team method is 45 so we're just gonna
give you guys a little intro right now
so that baby steps I like this analogy
which is when you go to a party and you
get hors d'oeuvres passed out to you and
you have an hors d'oeuvre and you eat it
and you're like oh that's good I want
some more you go back for more instead
of somebody trying to shove it
cheeseburger down your throat so I'm
just gonna give you a little bite-size
content right now just to warm you up so
you can feel what it feels like to
connect to this energy method so first
and foremost I just want to say again
thank you guys for coming on here right
now it's such a crazy time but you guys
are doing your part and in society by
social distancing and staying home and
that is first and foremost key so just
wrap yourself in love and hugs and just
give yourself some credit and awareness
there that that's what you guys are
doing I just want to give you guys that
acknowledgment too if you guys have
space just let's just take a second
first and foremost to just like breathe
connect to ourselves connect to our body
connect to our breath and surrender our
mind to our body right now we're in such
crazy time led by fear anxiety
uncertainty and all of that energy
literally can come up into your body and
either manifest into physical pain
emotional anxiety or yeah just like a
nervousness and fear so we just want to
be able to clear all that through this
next 15 minutes so let's just take a
second and close our eyes take a deep
breath in through your nose and breathe
out through your mouth if you want to
make some noise that is totally
appropriate breathing in through your
nose out through your mouth
just giving ourselves some time to
actually ground with all this frenetic
energy one more time in through your
nose out through your mouth and then
last time in through your nose out
through your mouth
so already my nervousness that I had
being on the line right now it just went
away and that was just because I breathe
so um let's get started I want you guys
to just rub your hands together for a
second like as fast as you can creating
some friction creating some heat and
activating our life force energy so now
I want you to just open your hands and I
want you to feel that energy between
your hands it's like a little buzzing
sensation if you feel it then that is us
activating our life force energy knowing
that what we're feeling right there is
what we're going to feel within our
entire body and then on the outside of
our body when we're finished with this
method so let's stand up rubbing our
hands together
maybe even just rubbing up and down our
arms or body or legs just waking ourself
up giving ourselves a little bit of love
giving ourselves permission to actually
touch our body because sometimes we get
so disconnected from our own body that
we don't even know that this is ours
we're just doing and walking and being
and we forget that this is our vessel
this is our our body to help us live
this life that we live so now that we're
connected to our life force we're
touching our body we're filling our body
I want to take you through a little
visualization so closing your eyes plant
your feet into the earth into your floor
into your living room your office
wherever you may be taking a deep breath
in through your nose out through your
mouth
I mean want you to just kind of like
shake off or just imagine like there's a
magnet being pull or pulling down all
this energy that's swirling around the
world right now and just having it being
pulled down into the center of the earth
and start visualizing activating your
imagination imagining it's just like
dripping off of your body and going down
down down deep into the earth and as
you're visualizing you can close your
eyes and I want you to just imagine what
it's like to start diving down into the
earth what does it taste like
what does it smell like is there dirt is
it mud what does the earth feel like
below your feet breathing in through
your nose out through your mouth
beautiful and as you go deeper into the
earth I want you to just surrender your
mind so this is why we're activating our
imagination so we can surrender all
those thoughts the chatter that's in our
head and just surrender it to the
imagination of what it feels like to
connect to the energy of Earth by
shooting all your breath all of your
energy everything down into the earth
and now I want you to go to the center
of the earth as far down as you can and
I want you to start bringing that earth
up through all the little crevices all
the little tunnels where the roots have
been growing bringing them up through
the bottoms of your feet breathing in
through your nose out through your mouth
and just allow it to like embrace and
envelop your feet and your calves up
into your knees taking a deep breath in
through your nose and out through your
mouth
[Applause]
so that energy method is movement breath
and visualization let's take a look at a
pair of pants again what do we notice
about these pants already we notice that
they're already folded so that the
crease is not rumpled right it's folded
you can fold it in twos or threes that's
up to you so I want to show you a quick
quick solution here for ironing pants
and for men especially a lot of men are
like I don't wanna iron pants are really
easy they're super easy you can't go
wrong because the fabrics are thicker so
they're more forgiving it's thinner
fabrics especially women's fabrics that
tend to be more delicate like silk
things like that this is easy so on this
iron by the we'll talk a little bit
about the mechanics of ironing we have
our iron and there's really only two
things you need to know you need to know
that it sprays water can you see that
water coming out it's getting my water
right so we use that because that
creates steam or you can just use the
steam function I do both so I have steam
coming out of here my role my role enta
at home my iron I named it don't we all
name our ions I call it the dragon
because the steam comes out way out here
so all I'm gonna do with this pair of
pants is I'm gonna start on no excuse me
I'm starting inside and I'm gonna go
like this
and notice the crease on these pants I
want a crease on some pants you don't
you've got a pair of cashmere chinos you
don't want to crease when you're going
out on Saturday for brunch fine
but these ones are meant to be creased
ok boom notice I'm going all the way up
alright I'm taking it all the way down
and I'm going over here now I notice a
couple more advanced things what am I
with my other hand this is what I
typically see beginners doing I'm not
doing anything what am i doing that
watch what do you guys see stretching
the fabric that's gonna stretch any
wrinkles out stretch it up notice also
this hand what am i doing again I'm
pointing
it's pushing creating force okay so I'm
stretching here and I'm also smoothing
out areas that need to be smoothed out
watch this this is a classic a little
bit more an intermediate mistake you
might make see this crease see this
crease right here let's get ins getting
tight on you we want this crease so
sharp it will cut your face now this is
a classic mistake what if I take this
crease and I go like this well now
you've done something horrific my
friends you have really screwed up that
crease you've got two creases that's a
double crease that's a mistake don't
ever do that okay you stretch it here
and you're going on one line one line
that gives you that beautiful single
crease like a face laughs s now you'll
just go on the outside we'll flip it
over we'll do the same thing inside
first and outside and then all you do is
just come in it skip through here open
it up Wow Wow wait let me zoom in on
that go in tight right here Wow now
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't worn
a pair of creased pants since you wore
Dockers to your seventh grade Sadie
Hawkins dance it's time to grow up my
friends it's time to join the twenty
twenty year of sub sartorial
celebrations that's what we're here to
talk about if you want more advice
wisdom guidance from other successful
entrepreneurs on how you can navigate
the coronavirus situation check out the
video right there next to me
I hope you find it valuable and continue
to believe and I'll see you there it's
the same thing every single day number
one accept it